thank you very much for the invitation
it's a pleasure to be here this is work
in progress with Kim pram at the
University of Nevada real and um let me
tell you the example that motivated the
analysis I'm going to show you and the
example was this move by hundreds of
universities to make in the last few
years to make the SAT optional in
college admissions so something that we
thought were interesting question to
think about was well how does this
affect the matching between colleges and
students
and who benefits from the movement from
a making it mandatory to take the SAT
and disclose it versus the case in which
it is voluntary yeah and one can even
think about intermediate cases where it
is voluntary to take it but then it's
mandatory to disclose it etc etc so we
were thinking about this type of issues
now if you look at this example there
are three features that are Salient one
is that there is something that you can
interpret as a costly pre premat
investment Nam spend the cost to take
the SAT in that case
yeah the second is that there is a
disclosure
opportunity and the the third one is
that there is a matching at the end of
the day between colleges and students
yeah and these three features are not
just particular to just the example I I
mentioned but you can also um come up
with similar examples in other matching
context for example think about matching
entrepreneurs with projects of different
qualities and venture capitalist who are
more or less experienced for example
there is there are papers on that and
one can think about some disclosure
opportunity in that setting as well what
do we do in the paper what we are what
we do is well we develop a matching
model with pre-at investment and
disclosure and there will be two sites
in this market with heterogeneous agents
on each side there will be no transfers
in what I'm going to show you today we
are thinking about the case with
transfer one side of the market can
costly find out an attribute that is pay
of relevant for the other side of the
market and then can choose to disclose
the observe attribute and after that
there will be a matching stage yeah of
the two sides of the mark so the key
forces at play here will be that a the
matching that at the last stage affects
incentives to invest and
disclose and the investment at
disclosure will affect the structure of
the matching at the end we are going to
see that and the main results that we um
that I'm going to show you is that well
we deriv equilibria or the set of
equilibrium equilibri in the modland We
compare the two cases of voluntary
versus mandatory
disclosure then one of the central
questions that we focus on is on the
analysis of who benefits from voluntary
disclosure and as an illustration I'll
come back after the analysis and tell
you what the analysis can say about this
optional sat example that I
mentioned um
literature and probably we have to add
many more papers but obviously there are
some seminal papers on
disclosure there are several papers on
matching with pre-match Investments but
they don't have the opportunity or allow
for disclosure and there are some recent
papers taking analyzing this optional
sat empirical work by borgan and osaki
and also there is another theory paper
that doesn't involve much in Us in in
this case but um also about um optional
test
taking um the model the model is fairly
simple to describe we're going to have
as I said a I'm going to label them
colleges and students but at this point
these are just labels yeah if you prefer
men and women venture capitalist
entrepreneurs firms and workers you can
choose the label you want at this point
but just for definiteness I'm going to
call it um
colleges there will be a measure one of
them that each college has a
characteristic or an attribute called s
distributed with a cdfg and positive
density a little G A Continuum of the
students also of measure one with a A
type T distributed AG with a positive
density and this just only observed by
the
students and students at a cost if you
want can
draw um an attribute X from a
conditional CDF a conditional on their
type and um and we have the conditional
density strictly
positive and the family of these
conditional densities will have common
support satisfy the strict monotone
likelihood ratio property
mlrp and if a student happens to pay the
cost and absorve the X then she can
decide whether to disclose that or
not and students who do not invest or
who invest best and do not
disclose look alike to the other side of
the
market and the payoffs very simple we
have so so for example the utility of a
student who is match with a college with
characteristic s is s and the utility of
a college who is matched with a student
who disclose an X is X we can there's
nothing changes if we assume
complementarities here in the payos of
the college as far as I can tell but I
need to check this carefully we can also
assume ment arities between s and X in
the payoff of the
students and after the pre-match
investment and disclosure matching will
take
place and our equilibrium concept will
be perfect ban equilibrium and we also
ask for the matching in the last stage
to be
stable
so let me tell you a let me start with
analysis of
equilibrium um so without loss we
restrict we can um focus on equilibria
that are in thresholds basically there
will be a threshold that we call TSA VV
for
voluntary such that every student with
type T bigger than TV will invest and
will disclose if the observe X will be
is bigger than a threshold X at
B regarding the
matching since the payoff of each side
is increasing in Partners
type matching will be postly assortative
so every there will be remember here the
distribution of the XIs that is observed
at the matching stage is endogenous
because it depends on who paid the cost
to observe the X so given that
distribution that is pinned down by the
TV and also who are the ones who
disclose and there will be a matching of
the x's and s's from the top down yeah
in a positive assortative way until you
reach XV XV is the expected value in
equilibrium is the expected value of x
conditional on students who either did
not invest or invested and did not
disclose and the matching function that
matches them positive assortatively easy
to Define in this case the only
complication is that the distribution of
x's is endogenous here but think of this
there is a function there that will
match everybody in a positiv assortative
way and the rest of the students the
ones who did not invest or did not
disclose will be mat randomly with the
remaining um
colleges now let's move backwards and
try to understand what will be the in
the the decision of each H student of
each type to um invest and to disclose
we can show here that notice that since
the t is irrelevant for matching later
on and basically it's very easy to show
that ER a students will everybody will
agree to disclose if students are using
this common rule of disclosing above
XV now given a threshold of TV yeah
let's try to understand the incentives
of a type T to um invest or not in
finding out this attribute X so the if
you want the marginal is a marginal
benefit marginal cost yeah so the
marginal benefit for type t yeah so here
index by and it is the the marginal
benefit is the expected payoff sorry the
the expected utility gross
um without the cost of investing and
that that is with probability with some
probability X will be bigger than XV
you're going to disclose and you're
going to get the expected value of s
that you're are going to be matched with
in the second stage and with with the
complimentary probability you're not
going to disclose because the x is less
than XV and you get the payoff from
random
matching and um if you don't invest you
get the payoff from random matching
because you know that you're going to
look alike in the in the stage of match
so basically if that call all this
expression the marginal benefit for T of
investing when everybody else is using
the threshold TV if is bigger than C
then T will invest and by the mlrp
property of the that we assume this
increasing in T and therefore there will
be a unique C of TLD V that above which
this student will
um invest and Below will not
invest but in equilibrium it has to be
the case that the t is the same as the
TV so the equilibrium condition at least
for an interor equilibrium will be that
the marginal benefit of the marginal
type TSA V when everybody else is using
TSA V is equal to
C and we can also have the conditions
for an equilibrium where everybody
invests and also an equilibrium where
nobody invests so so we can cover all
the cases in this case and for any any
cost of discovering this attribute there
exist an equilibrium but there could be
multiple and the here just
a a picture depicting um free equilibria
in this
case okay what can we say with
this well before we I I show you some
comparisons
here let me introduce two Benchmark
cases against which we are going to
compare um the equilibria in the
voluntary case so the first case is a
very trivial Benchmark fully mandatory
we call it basically every student must
invest and must disclose yeah so if that
is the case matching is very simple
because essentially the the marginal
distribution of the X's yeah is
everybody's investing here so it's easy
to pin down and um you match this with
the G which is distribution of the 's
and basically the payoff for each
student in that case will be the
expected match they are going to get
after the x is realized minus the cost c
yeah from an exante
perspective and if we allow students to
drop out of the market if it is not
individually rational for them to
essentially spend that cost then there
will be a threshold type T
TFM above which the students stay below
which students drop out if you want that
they will not invest they will not be in
the market pres in the second stage yeah
so that's why trivial Benchmark that we
are going to talk about the other
Benchmark um is more interesting but
it's an intermediate case suppose that
now we allow for voluntary pretty much
investment so you you decide whether to
spend the cost or
not and um but if you do spend the cost
and You observe the X it is
automatically disclosed yeah so it's
mandatory disclosure of that so once
again the equilibrium will involve now
just one threshold TM above which all
T's will invest the X will be revealed
and therefore
disclosed and the matching in the second
stage well there will be a threshold xn
where xn is the expectation of X
conditional the set of students who do
not invest and given the thresold
TM and above that XM we have this
positive assortative matching yeah of
the highest X's the highest s's yeah
until you reach
xn the next tier of students who are the
ones who did not invest will be randomly
match to an intermediate set of colleges
in this case and then the lowest X is
observed will be much positively
assortative the lower tail but starting
from X end down and again I have the the
for the distributions are endogenous
here again I have the formulas for this
but essentially
all you have to do is to compute what is
the distribution of exes that is present
in the market and then make sure that
you have this positive assortativeness
which is the one that is giving you
stability in this case we showed that in
the case and as in many disclosure
papers you have you need to worry about
off path beliefs that will sustain
things here but it's it's pretty easy to
do that and something that I forgot to
say is that in the voluntary case that I
showed you before the issue why we don't
have unraveling is the fact that if you
do not disclose you can hide among the
ones who didn't invest yeah and the
other side of the market you look alike
as either who did not have any bad news
to report that you hit them or that you
didn't invest all
together so here in this case if you we
look at the decision to invest again
there will be a marginal Ben benefit
here which is consist of the difference
between the pay of gross of the cost the
expected pay of gross of the cost of
investing yeah which is the probability
that your X is above xn and you are
match positively
assortatively with the top people or it
is below xent and you are match with the
low tail yeah of the colleges versus not
investing all together and you get the
payoff from random
matching and one once again um we can
have the equilibrium condition check the
boundary cases you can have multiple
equilibria there's always existence etc
etc so let me tell you what we do with
all this so the first thing is that we
compare voluntary disclosure the set of
equilibria there with the case in which
it is voluntary to invest and observe
your attribute but it is mandatory to
disclosing and here is what we have a
the first thing we show is that there is
more investment in the voluntary case
than in the mandatory
case if you think that Suppose there is
a unique equilibrium and suppose that
you in the mandatory case you give the
option to invest to one of the students
of TI te it's obvious that this student
will have more invest more incentive to
invest in the voluntary case than in the
mandatory case but obviously there is
also the equilibrium effect if you give
the option to everybody so this direct
effect can cannot be do we show that
it's not dominated by the indirect
effect the equilibrium
effect and if you have we we actually
have also if we don't if you don't have
a unique equilibrium we have a set
comparison that basically what we show
is that the set of equilibrium
thresholds under voluntary
investment is a higher sorry a under
mandatory investment is a higher set in
the weak order set of CH Kim and Kojima
21 than the set of um equilibrium
thresholds under the voluntary case this
gives you an idea even the setwise
comparison that there is more investment
in the voluntary than in the
mandatory and we have something similar
for the case of the intervales of the
interval of values of c that sustain
equilibria in the voluntary versus the
mandatory case yeah and basically what
we show is that the interval of values
of c that sustain inter for example
interior equilibria under voluntary case
is a higher set so voluntary equilibrium
can bear higher cost of investment and
still invest than in the case of the
mandatory
case and roughly the idea is the the
marginal benefit under voluntary case
even when you plug um even in
equilibrium is higher than in the
mandatory so again I have the the
propositions here but I prefer to skip
since I want to show you the welfare or
the analys or the who benefits on this
the other thing that we compare is what
we call the amount of disclosure the
mass of students disclosing an X and
there are two counter bailing forces on
the one hand this result here shows you
that in the voluntary case more people
invest yeah so a higher mass of people
is investing but on the other hand in
the voluntary case you
censor the with the threshold the
disclosure so there are these two forces
here and and therefore the comparison is
amb ous but we can show that um at least
for a set of low values of c or a set of
high values of
c there is more disclosure under
voluntary investment in the voluntary
case yes you don't make any assumption
about productivity of investment right
it just reveals X exactly exactly we we
don't make and we are still exploring
some variations but yeah for for now
it's the simplest case that we
have so as I said for for example for an
interval of low values of
c given the result that we show
here what we can show is that there
is um an interval of C's where under
voluntary in the voluntary case
everybody invests yeah but in the
mandatory case only a fraction invests
so that that that gives you the and that
essentially tame the two forces in the
and in the dire direction of more more
disclosure the amount of disclosure be
higher in the voluntary disclosure and
the opposite for high
seas now what else do we do now we start
looking at our
um our analysis of who benefits from
voluntary disclosure
and first we compare voluntary
disclosure with that Benchmark the fully
mandatory Yeah so basically you must
invest and you must disclose with or
without the option to drop out and here
is the proposition we have um if you
compare voluntary discloser versus fully
mandatory there is a the first part says
that you can always find an interval of
low
Ts that start at
zero that strictly prefers voluntary
disclosure to the fully mandatory
case and then part two and I will tell
you why we add this if the family of
conditional densities is tp3 I remind
you tp2 is the monotone likelihood ratio
property tp3 is a strengthening of
that then we can pin down who benefits
and who um is hurt for for example then
either all students strictly prefer
voluntary disclosure or there is a
threshold below which all T prefer
voluntary disclosure and the rest fully
mandatory or there is a of intermediate
types that strictly prefers the fully
mandatory and everybody else prefers the
voluntary
disclosure
so not as strong as we would like this
to be but the comparison of the expected
payoffs in the two regimes these are
highly nonlinear functions there we
could have million thousands of these
different intervals where you have some
benefits some um are hurt so I think
it's a we are still go a long way
pinning down um the the intervals of who
benefits and the voluntary disclosure
and who benefits under fully mandatory
is there is there an easy intuition
about see why why do high types prefer
voluntary
um can we wait and I will show you a
simpler case and maybe we can come back
to that yeah
the so so part
one the the way to think about it is
that if you are a low
type under the fully mandatory case
you're you are match with a pretty low
College under the voluntary case you are
randomly matched so so and we it takes
some work but we we we showed that um
basically that that effects dominate in
that case for part two how we discipline
this well there is this beautiful old
results by Carling the variation
diminishing property that I'm sure most
of you know and basically what we do is
the following um very easy to discipline
what happens for all the types below TV
because the the the difference between
the pay off under voluntary disclosure
versus the pay off under fully mandatory
starts a strictly positive by one that
doesn't require anything for that and
then goes down but what happens Beyond
TV Beyond
TV one can show that the difference in
the pay expected payoff between
voluntary and mandatory can be written
in this way this a very complicated
function R but can be written as this
integral now one can show also that this
R here as a function of X is piecewise
continuous and changes signs at most
twice and if it changes signs exactly
twice it does going from positive to
negative and then to positive
again now Carling variation diminishing
property tells you that in this case the
same number of
Crossings call for n as a function of
T and if it has exactly two Crossings as
a function of T they also have the same
pattern and this exactly what pins down
C here and and and and B and a basically
that's the idea
compared to um if we compare voluntary
disclosure with that intermediate case
that I told you where it's voluntary to
invest in the attribute but it is
mandatory to disclose it we have a
similar result we have there is an
interval of low types starting at zero
that strictly prefer the mandatory
disclosure case now to the voluntary
case and part two now we need a
strengthening with tp4 then we have
either everybody prefers voluntary
disclosure or everybody below a
threshold prefers oh that that's wrong
it should say here mandatory
disclosure here mandatory and here here
and here voluntary disclosure or there
are one or two intervals of intermediate
site that prefer voluntary while the
rest prefers the mandatory disclosure so
there is a typo
there and and here the first part is
much easier than in the other case
because
remember random matching under the
mandatory case that I told you before is
a you match all the X High ex's with 's
then
intermediate colleges 's randomly match
with the students who did not invest and
then the low types are matched assort
assortatively again but in the voluntary
case you match assortatively until XV
and then everybody else random on
average you get a higher payoff because
he say higher set of 's that you are
match with randomly in the mandatory
than in the voluntary case so this the
the Rand the pay from the random match
in the in the mandatory and this in the
voluntary case and this accounts for one
and for two is exactly the same
application of Carling um variation
diminishing
property so er we can say much
more if we restrict attention to the
population of colleges having only just
two characteristics yeah so think about
a fraction Kappa with characteristic X1
and a f fraction one minus Kappa with
characteristic S2 is strictly bigger
than S1 so we can think of S2 as the top
schools yeah and we can think of S1 as
colleges that are non-top schools and
one minus Capa and Kappa can be thought
of as the aggregate capacity of top and
non-top
schools so if we focus on equilibria
where
the random matching gives you at least
some probability of ending up at a top
school and we can ensure that from
Primitives then we can say much
more we can say that basically the
welfare exhibits this a single Crossing
property there will be a threshold T hat
below which everybody prefers voluntary
disclosure to fully mandatory and above
which everybody prefers fully
mandatory and the inition and let me see
if I can start um coming back to your
question intuition is
that in the fully mandatory
case if you are match with the college
two you are match deterministically
there but in the voluntary case you are
mat with some probability you match
deterministically at to some point
depending on your X but then there is
some probability that you are matched
randomly and therefore in that case for
high enough T they would prefer fully
mandatory because they are will be much
for sure with S2 or with a higher
probability because
it's and regarding the the first chunk
the low types well the thing is that
being much randomly gives you a higher
payoff than being much for sure with
college one basically that that that
part dominates in that
case and then
regarding the comparison between
voluntary disclosure and the
intermediate case where it's voluntary
to um invest but mandatory to disclose
we have also that again there is a
single Crossing and basically there is a
t tilder a bigger strictly bigger than
TSA B such that everybody below that
prefers mandatory disclosure everybody
above prefers voluntary
disclosure and again for high of
T the possibility of disclosure provides
an extra benefit and this what accounts
for the fact that high ties prefer the
voluntary disclosure in this case
and for low n oft random matching that
gives you a higher payoff than being
assigned deterministically to than
having a low X and getting a low College
assignment dominates in that
case we have sorry here let's go back in
the last two minutes that I have to the
optional sat interpret now a drawing X
as taking the SAT yeah so you have some
idea of your ability and then you take
the SAT and this x reveals your ability
for sure that's a restriction here is
simplistic we can add some noise but we
we haven't done it yet so but notice
that what we learn from the previous
analysis is that well low caliber
students strictly prefer this voluntary
regime to the previous regime where you
had to take the SAT if you wanted to
apply to college and report
it but we also showed that if you worry
about benefiting low tees that maybe you
associate with low-income students with
low access to high quality school high
school or coaching etc etc then there is
an an even better regime which is
basically that where it's voluntary to
to take it but then it's mandatory to
report and at least in the case of top
and non top schools High Caliber
students H prefer the voluntary case to
the mandatory case
moreover we if if you think about the
fully mandatory case with the option to
drop out there are more applications and
voluntary disclosure and that under the
fully mandatory case these are things
that in the empirical papers that I told
you appear in one form or
another we have more results but that I
thought were going to come up in
questions but let me stop
here let me stop here and this is the
summary um application and here is what
we are working on trying to understand
better the the welfare also in the
college side efficiency adding noise and
thinking about transfers as well in the
setting for other applications that one
might look
at that's
it any question yes the reason as I
understand it the reason we have
opal is that people think in terms of
the model that has two dimensional types
there's a real quality that colies care
about and there is some ability to
succeed at the SAT which is correlated
with quality and we don't want we don't
want to take that that into account so
that's a bit of a different it's
interesting that you don't have these
ingredients and you I I agree but and
also as I said it's a very Stark
assumption that that this x which is the
SAT will reveal perfectly your ability
and so so I agree I I I point well taken
and it will be nice to analyze that case
that you have in
mind adding the two
Dimensions yes
please if this doesn't
take there's no signal at all that no no
EX exctly so so
again say again random you just look
identical to the other
side no no no in reality in reality no
because the SATs that's that's what I
was saying that it's very restrictive to
assume that the SAT reveals everything
about you yeah when you apply to college
there are many other things that you you
apply with so that's a something to
embellish them all
yeah oh you have one
okay I'm the next